One of my arguments has been that Kimmy Schmidt
is a sixties gimmick sitcom that's been updated
for the 2010s.
The premise of Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt is
that Kimmy Schmidt, herself, was in a bunker
for many many years.
After she was rescued she decides that she's
going to stay in New York City.
She's gone from this world of terrible terrible
trauma to a world where everything is bursting
with new opportunity and the color represents
that in many ways.
Television has had color since the 1960s but
it's one of those things where a lot of shows
haven't had time to really build out color
pallets.
Now we've had some great shows with lots of
color in them.
Pushing Daisies is one that comes to mind.
There's a show where everything in it was
color coordinated.
That's from creator Brian Fuller who frequently
does such things.
He also does tremendous work with color on
Hannibal where he uses rich blood reds to
accent the scenes of death and horror.
Kimmy Schmidt definitely wants to signal to
you that this is taking place in a weird heightened
world.
Kimmy and Titus the roomates, they're both
often colored in just very bright accent colors
that stand out from the rest of the scene
or if you look carefully are often color coordinated
with sets and with the props around them.
Another example would be Jacqueline who is
the woman that Kimmy works for.
She's very often in dressed in whites, beiges,
things that sort of blend in with her environment.
She is a woman who is from the very rich upper
class world and so she, of course, doesn't
want to rock the boat too much and her color
reflects that.
And finally the guy that kidnapped Kimmy is
always in very white and black tones.
This sort of represents, kind of, his religious
world view but it also represents that fact
that he's trying to drag Kimmy back to a world
of monochrome.
I think episode 6, in general, is really interesting
in terms of color coordination.
When Kimmy is at school where she's trying
to get her GED from a teacher who just doesn't
care, he's again, dressed in sort of the colors
of white of beige.
The monochrome is the hue of the people who
are trying to keep Kimmy down on this show.
Where as Kimmy is dressed in a very bright
green that contrasts well with the green of
the blackboards and with everybody around
her.
This is a show that, I think, has a couple
of small issues here and there but it's definitely
a show that, by the end of season one, I was
very much in to.
I just really want to spend more time in this
world because it's so interesting and colorful
and unlike anything else on television.